Jordan peels us had the best opening of
any original horror movie in box office
history it also enjoyed lowing reviews
with critics raving about Lupita
nyong'o's dual performance but how
exactly did she share scenes with
herself to find out we spoke to
oscar-nominated VFX supervisor Grady
Cofer he explained how his team at
Industrial Light and Magic made the
doppelganger scenes in us so realistic
plus he let us in on how the film's most
memorable shots came to life and what
they really mean about the movie beware
some spoilers ahead Grady Studio ILM has
worked on a long list of blockbusters
including Black Panther Aquaman and
Avengers infinity war while those films
are known for the scope of their VFX us
required a lighter touch you know
there's no robots there's no kind of big
space battle at the end you know all of
the kind of big summer blockbuster kind
of movie tropes that cover kind of used
to do it that's kind of in our
wheelhouse this isn't a movie about kind
of showy kind of grandiose effects in
fact they all kind of live in the world
of subtlety in a film where pretty much
every actor played two roles
ILM couldn't rely on the split screen
technique long used in twin movies going
back to the original Parent Trap instead
they went through the exacting process
of piecing together parts of different
shots often doing extensive head and
face swaps so in some scenes you might
be seeing a hybrid of say Winston Dukes
face with parts of his stunt doubles
body to get all the footage the islands
artists would need for source material
the actors had to perform scenes twice
once for each of their roles Lupita for
instance would first play red with her
body or photo double playing Adelaide
when that was done we David switched
places right she would go to costume
wardrobe reset we took very very careful
on like
you know notes about what the camera was
doing what the light was doing and we
would essentially recreate the shot
right so in in effect you're almost
making the movie twice where it really
becomes a challenge is when the
characters are interacting and that
happened a lot the most dramatic of
these scenes is the final battle between
red and Adelaide phimax of this movie is
not only the confrontation between you
know the two versions of Adelaide but
it's also this kind of pinnacle moment
in their past when they were both
getting these expressive kind of artists
and they were expressing what they were
going through or through dams even the
fight is a dance
and so this was extremely careful and
and like methodical choreography of how
they would interact together we really
had to plan it out you kind of figure
out okay who was kind of the hero of the
shot meaning who is the one who's kind
of controlling the action most based on
those factors they decide which parts of
the shot would need to get swapped
painted or grafted in post-production it
often was a head replacement or
sometimes we had to have the arm of one
character because it was you know
attaching to the neck of Lupita
after weeks of rehearsing they shot the
fight over a period of two days and then
they kind of end in some kind of embrace
this incredibly difficult shot to pull
off is a really good artist at ILM
people that were row tubing parts of
bodies they were painting and a lot of
things that were included and they kind
of pieced it all back together and at
the end of the day you know you just had
to buy these were two people that were
actually grappling together they filmed
a fight inside their underworld set
which was designed with moveable walls
that could be rolled away at any point
to reveal a green screen
this meant that ILM could digitally
extend the hallway making it look like
an endless tunnel whenever Jordan wanted
he waited to this one moment at the very
end kind of a pinnacle of that fight and
you come behind both of them and you see
that hallway kind of extend to infinity
of course at the same time the song that
5:00 on and you're gonna remix it's like
its loudest moment you know
theatres kind of shaking it's a
hair-raising climax of course we learned
soon after that that this wasn't the
first time red and Adelaide faced off
they had their first encounter as little
girls inside the Hall of Mirrors for
this flashback Jordan was clear that he
didn't want the two girls to look like
mirror images of each other instead of
having them face each other right they
they actually good go back to back I
mean there was something really uncanny
about looking at the back of someone's
head like that so he kind of holds on
that for a second Adelaide then turns
around and red reaches out to strangle
her at first they tried shooting the
struggle with the actor Madison Currie
opposite a photo double but to get a
truly terrifying shot kuri needed
something that she could really grab on
to so they had her grip a paper cup
which was wrapped and green so that it
could get digitally replaced later on
different action in that case we are
using different hands than the arms that
is actually a head replacement as well
you wouldn't know it but it's another
kind of part of the shot that makes it
slightly unnerving that you're actually
seeing something that's kind of pieced
together peel is known for his attention
to all of these tiny visual details
throughout us he slipped an imagery of
mirrors breaking glass and refracted
light a voguing the film's central theme
of duality
Grady's team worked with the director to
sneak these clues into every frame one
example is when Adelaide is pushed into
a glass table and her face lines up
perfectly with Reds reflection in the
glass
Jordan noticed this splitting image when
Lupita was playing the role of red so
they framed down on her reflection and
ILM superimposed it right next to
Adelaide's face what really drew me to
this material was that the premise was
so intricately tied to the visual effect
for this story in this movie to work all
of that has to be incredibly seamless